while president joe biden pretends that
his policies have not
created a crisis and a surge at the
southern border
the criminal coyotes who his
policies have empowered are saying
otherwise take a listen i'll translate
since i'm such an expert in spanish and
i can read subtitles
is business booming right now does it
pay well it does
given the situation with the people at
least that's what these two young men
say having built a highly profitable
business this is univision
by helping central american families
seeking asylum to cross into the u.s
we just come here to earn our daily
bread like everybody else says the
criminal coyote
in all honesty there are way too many
people with the benefits your president
is now granting
you know look man who am i i'm just a
small criminal coyote who abuses people
and breaks the laws of multiple nations
but man
your president is insane your president
is serious it's too much all right
please
we're getting too rich off of this say
the gangsters i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from austin faust
who says anytime a democrat says it's
not about politics
it is definitely about politics this is
true this is
uh this is the tell you know the the
democrats are very often misdirecting
and the left
usually projects so what it accuses uh
its opponent
its opponents of doing is what it is
doing itself and it's the same thing
this irony of
hey come on this is not about politics
just
redefine sex obliterate national borders
and give us all the power it's not about
politics come on
not about but with with people so power
hungry sometimes it's hard to relax
though if you do want to relax if you
want to be in a really really
comfortable position
whether you're doing work whether you're
sitting around reading a book you've got
to check out
x-chair x-chair has you covered for your
office chair
needs the secret is not only their
patented dynamic variable
lumber support which offers unbelievable
lumbar support
to your lower back but now thanks to
their new
xhmt technology you can also get heat
and massage therapy while you're sitting
at your desk i'm not kidding
you know here at the daily wire ben
basically wants me to sit on like a
little footstool
while i do my work all day to get even
any chair was really
really a big deal for me and i tried out
this x chair
it is it is ridiculous you get the
massage function going
you're sitting up really nice your
posture is much better
it's i i did not know a chair could be
so advanced
and sophisticated the x chair is on sale
now for 100
off go to xchairknowles.com right now
that's the letter x
chair canon wlas.com or call
one eight four four four x chair x chair
has a 30 day guarantee of complete
comfort
and you can finance your purchase for as
little as 30 bucks a month seriously
invest in your work i i do that and i
really don't regret it we spend a lot of
time working
go to ex chair knowles kenner wlas.com
now use code
xwheels for free xwheel bladecasters
xchairknowles.com aoc
says that i am not supposed to call what
is going on
at the border a surge or a crisis
i'm not allowed to do that just because
the numbers are surging just because we
obviously have a crisis
1500 capacity in some detention
facilities i'm not allowed to call it
either of those things because that
would make me
a racist they want to say what about the
surge
well first of all just
gut check stop anyone who's using the
term
surge around you consciously
is trying to invoke a militaristic frame
and that's a problem because
these this is not a surge these are
children and they are not insurgents
and we are not being invaded which by
the way
is a white supremacist
idea philosophy the idea
that if an other is coming in the
population
that this is like an invasion of who we
are
invasion is a white supremacist
word so for instance when
uh like genghis khan's
armies were taking over and conquering
lands that was
that was white supremacy when the greeks
invaded troy that was white supremacy
were the trojans white or the greeks
white i'd
uh ed as just a technical matter
what is going on at the southern border
is an
invasion now the reason that one can
hesitate to call it an invasion
there are two reasons one the the people
who are coming in the foreign nationals
pouring across our border illegally
are not armed and usually that the idea
of an invasion involves people being
armed preparing for armed conflict and
they're not which ties into the second
reason
that one hesitates to call it an
invasion namely they're being invited in
by democrats
joe biden is actually saying come surge
get over here come on
we want you to come he's using all those
white supremacist terms
but just as a as a purely technical
matter take all the emotion out of it
when a when a foreign people subject to
a foreign state
starts lawlessly pouring across your
border
in contravention of your of your
national borders of your sovereignty and
of your laws what do you call that
do you call that a dinner party no is it
closer to a dinner party or an invasion
i
it seems to me very much the latter but
but she goes further than that
she says you can't call it a surge
they're not it's not a surge it's
children
yeah children can surge yes if you when
we're talking about the surge we're
talking about a rapid increase
in numbers and that is just what's
happening
doesn't matter if it you can call it a
surge in bunny rabbits
at the local park it's not a surge it's
bunny rabbits right we're just talking
about the massive increase
in numbers that you're seeing because of
joe biden it's not a crisis
we're just oh right putting kids in
cages that same thing that aoc pretended
to cry about when trump did it
even though the policy wasn't even
originally a trump policy it's a policy
that dates back all the way
to the clinton administration so
so dishonest and what she does it works
obviously i fell for it
she she says things that are patently
absurd like
when people come in mass over a border
illegally you can't call that
an invasion or you're a white
supremacist and when numbers
increase you can't call it a surge and
when you're in a at a critical moment
you can't call it a crisis so she says
things that are just incoherent
indefensible and then she gets all of us
to be exasperated by it but then the
terms of the discussion
are on her preferred battlefield
right this is what the left always does
they get us to argue on
their terms and so and we're doing it
right now i mean the reason i'm i'm
bringing this story up right now is just
to call
your attention to this rhetorical and
political technique
and to call your attention to the
central strategy of political
correctness which i detail quite a lot
in my book speechless controlling words
controlling minds
available now for pre-order which is
that they believe that if you redefine
the words
you can redefine reality if i say it's
not a crisis then you know what it's not
a crisis
if i say that a whole lot of foreigners
are
not boring across our border i don't
even know what the argument she's making
is then yeah then they're really not
it's not a surge it's not a surge
speaking of redefining reality
the actress sophia bush who is that i
have no idea but apparently she's a
somewhat well-known actress she just
posted to her instagram
that that not pumping little boys
full of little girl hormones not pumping
little kids
full of cross-sex hormones and
mutilating their bodies
is tantamount to murder
yes hashtag trans kids are under attack
across the country
ar i guess arkansas just banned them
from accessing health care oh they can't
oh no they can't they can't get their
annual checkup they can't go to the
hospital if they have
appendicitis they oh no they have health
care uh
ar just won't uh won't allow them to it
won't allow
pervert parents to pump their kids full
of cross-sex hormones
this is tantamount to murder kids will
tell us who they are
it's our job to support them not
demonize or harm them no it's our job to
raise them and educate them and kids
won't tell us who they are because i
told my mother i was batman when i was
four years old
kids will tell us who they are no no if
if you are relying on kids to teach you
about the world and to educate you then
something has gone very wrong in your
life you are
you are living an inverted sort of life
but it this does bring i mean who cares
what some ridiculous actress says
there are three positions that you can
take on this transgender
issue and it involves a whole lot more
than just this issue of
people who are confused about their sex
which is as a psychological matter a
very small number of people as a social
contagion it's getting bigger
but there are three positions you can
have the one is the
the first one is the leftist position
which is men can be women
and therefore we ought to be able to
mutilate anyone we want
if we want to pump adults full of
hormones and chop off their body parts
that's
totally fine that's their choice that's
wonderful we we should do that actually
and if kids want to do that then we
should indulge kids in that too
that's the leftist position then there
is the call it the libertarian position
which is men cannot be women but hey who
am i to judge
you do you i mean look i think men can't
be women but maybe you think men can be
women and so you know really
who's to say so you you should mutilate
adults
but you shouldn't mutilate children
because they haven't reached the age of
consent
and so you got to wait for them to
decide to harm themselves
and then once they want to harm
themselves then they can do that
libertarian position third position is
the conservative position which is
men cannot be women and therefore we
should not encourage this
and therefore we should not mutilate
anyone
this is the position of dr paul mchugh
who or at least in his practice this is
his position he was one of the pioneers
of the gender reassignment
surgery the very sort of mutilation that
we're talking about he did this at johns
hopkins
and he stopped doing it he shut he shut
that down because he realized it wasn't
providing any medical benefit
and it was wrong to do
i would strongly recommend the
conservative position here i think a lot
of conservatives who want to be like
nice guys and you know they don't want
to tell people what to think and
hey come on it doesn't affect me man or
whatever they they believe
that by arguing the number two position
the the libertarian position
that you know just don't do it to kids
yeah men can't really be women but
whatever
adults should be able to do whatever
they want so just don't do it to kids
they
think that that is going to
stave off the leftist position that we
should
be able to do it to everybody including
pumping little kids full hormones
it won't that second permissive position
is just going to grant the premises that
the first one relies on
there is such a thing as reality we can
know certain things about reality
through
our faculties of reason we can know
certain things about the moral universe
like doctors shouldn't mutilate
we can know that through our moral
conscience which is a judgment of reason
and if we're going to abandon our
faculties of reason and our moral
conscience
then we've just given the game away to
the leftists who believe that they can
redefine reality however they see fit
you are not staving off what what you
feel
is the the really bad part of this which
is really the worst part of it the the
mutilating kids you're not staving that
off by adopting the
live and let live you do you position
you have to
grow the cojones to stay that's a
kind of an interesting metaphor to use
in this topic you have to be able to
grow those body parts a spine too would
be a good one
to be able to state truths and have the
confidence
to stand by those truths in the public
square and to stand by those truths
through self-government where we make
our own laws rather than surrender the
field
to the radicals who are who are
engaging in vicious vicious behaviors
that are ruining countless lives now
including the lives
of children if you want to
work on your body you know work out a
little bit working out is great
for instance on the total gym the total
gym fit gives me a full body workout in
the comfort of my home
for about half the price of those
expensive fitness bikes you can do
over 85 exercises on one machine
whether you're a beginner or you're
advanced they have everything you need
to get in the best shape of your life
burn calories and lose weight
you can work your core your arms your
shoulders your biceps your thighs
you can work your whole body in a
complete workout takes just 10 to 20
minutes a day
even i you know i'm not the biggest
hulking adonis of a man
i set up my total gym fit i love it it's
terrific it's so because
you know if you're going to go to the
gym it's like you got to get dressed you
go to the gym you drive 20 minutes to
the gym you go work out for however long
you've got a shower you drive back
the whole thing it takes an hour and a
half for you to get like a 15 minute
workout
when you got that total gym fit in your
home you just go right upstairs it's so
easy that's a real real workout
right now total gym is offering a 30 day
in-home trial on the total gym fit for
just one dollar
one dollar so what do you have to lose
do you not trust
christy brinkley do you not trust chuck
norris do you not trust me
no matter which total gym you try my
listeners can get an additional 20
off whatever discount they're currently
running go to totalgymdirect.com knowles
to get this offer
you've got to go to that url
totalgymdirect.com to get an additional
20 off moving on from the topic of the
gender ideology but still speaking
of dubious medical advice dr fauci
dr fauci is out there the exalted doctor
peace be upon him our
our great spiritual leader in his
beautiful white lab coat
telling all of us what we need to do not
according to any traditional moral order
or political order just kind of whatever
whims pop into his mind fauci is
claiming credit
for the vaccine he is saying that this
vaccine
we got already it's so great this is the
best decision
that he ever made when i saw what
happened
in new york city refrigerated trucks are
now
being mobilized as makeshift works
almost
over running of our health care system
it was like
oh my goodness and that's when it became
very clear
that the decision we made on january the
10th
to go all out and develop a vaccine we
have a number of vaccine candidates
may have been the best decision that
i've ever made with regard
to an intervention as the director of
the institute
wow thank you dr fauci dr fauci was the
only person
who thought that we should try to
develop a vaccine to the new virus right
he's the only person on earth who
thought oh no
everyone else thought that too and
president trump is pushing for that
more than just about anybody well okay
fine maybe it wasn't his idea dr fauci's
but at least he was the one who said
this is what we're gonna do this is the
timeline here's how we're gonna get it
done right
he was the one leading the charge he was
the one
who who foresaw that we would be able to
get this vaccine into oh no he didn't he
actually said it was
absurd to think we were going to get a
vaccine really even by
right about now that we wouldn't we
wouldn't have a vaccine for a year
a year and a half certainly not in the
six months it actually took
one of the things the president said
yesterday is that we're very close
to a vaccine now i know this is
something you know a lot about this is
your job
how close are we to a vaccine are we
very close well i mean the confusion
again
is we're close to starting a phase one
trial
to determine safety we're going to do
that in about one and a half
to two months but that doesn't mean you
have a vaccine
in order to get a vaccine that's
practically deployable
for people to use it's going to be at
least a year to a year and a half
at best so that interview was at the
very end of february two days before the
end of february
and he said you will not get a vaccine
you will not you will not have a vaccine
forget about
widespread access to the vaccine you
won't even have the vaccine
for a year so that would bring us to
right about now
or a year and a half a year and a half
that would bring us to
september of 2021
when did we actually get the vaccine got
the vaccine in
late october early i mean ready to go
sort of vaccine late october
early november of 2020.
completely wrong about the vaccine
like he was completely wrong about so
many important aspects of this pandemic
but he's going to get the credit he's
going to get the nice cnn special dr
fauci saved us donald trump
stood on a debate stage with joe biden
being interrogated by chris wallace
and he was told wallace i wish i had the
clip wallace said repeatedly i've played
it on the show before
he said mr president you've said we're
going to get a vaccine by the fall but
all the medical experts say there's no
way that's going to happen
trump says look i don't know what to
tell you i talk to these companies it's
going to happen
no it's not all the experts all the
geniuses all the lab guys
look i don't know i mean look man i'm
just donald trump what do i know i'm a
reality tv show host but i think i'm
smarter than all these eggheads and
their white coats
he didn't quite say that but he implied
it and he was right
and he was right
some people are benefiting from the
continued lockdowns
and i think that is why some people
technocrats
politicians certain people in corporate
america
are encouraging us to maintain the
lockdowns longer and longer and longer
the lockdowns are not universally bad
for business
we have this idea that all the lockdowns
shut down terrible for the economy
what's the economy but you know we have
this abstraction of the economy the
economy is
how we all get along in our livelihoods
how we all make some money
how companies thrive how companies go
under and some companies are doing
really really well
what's going on in this lockdown is not
that
the economy is suffering it's that
big business interests big political
interests
are getting everything they've wanted
for years
and little business interests and little
political interests
are getting absolutely wrecked
the power mad democrats are getting
everything they want the administrative
state the public health apparatus
getting everything at once
giant corporations amazon notably but
many many others
have never been doing better because now
we're all just at home ordering from
them instead of going to our local
local shops the cdc
has now extended its moratorium on
evictions
through june okay well that's good
that's good for the little guy right
well maybe maybe it's good for some
people who can't pay their rent
but what about the landowners what about
the building owners now i know what
you're thinking oh who cares about my
landlord that guy drives me crazy always
takes my money
not all landlords are made the same
there are small landlords
who maybe they own one one apartment
building
maybe they own one apartment i used to
rent an apartment from a lovely
couple that they owned one apartment and
they rented it out
and so if you didn't pay your rent that
month that really
mattered to them they couldn't they
couldn't float you for
a year or a year and a half that would
put them out of business
the same is true for small property
developers it's not like these guys are
just swimming around in
bathtubs full of money a lot of them are
pretty extended you know they need to
collect that rent
for much larger land developers
it's a little bit easier because they
divorce diversify their portfolio
they are able to float cash a little a
little bit more easily
so large land owners i don't think they
they mine this at all
make sure extend them the eviction
moratorium extend it all you want
because it's going to squeeze those
small landlords out of business
and then the big guys are going to be
able to come in this is the theme
of covet the little guy suffers and the
big guy wins
the little guy has to wear the mask the
little guy can't go to thanksgiving the
little guy can't leave his house
and the big guy he does whatever he
wants
just look at the cuomo's in new york
violated
all of andrew cuomo's mandates
chris cuomo lied about it on tv goes
to the hamptons starts bicycling all
around sees people
gets fast-tracked all the special
medical care gets to go to work every
day but
but you the little guy the little guy
doesn't get any of that
speaking of the powerful oppressing the
powerless
a theme we hear a whole lot especially
from the left in our politics
a georgia police department gwinnett
county pd
is requiring officers to complete an
implicit
bias training course okay we've heard a
lot about implicit bias
the course teaches that the criminal
justice system was quote
set up by white men to benefit white men
quote each of these systems were set up
by white men to benefit white men that
is not to lay blame
simply to explain how practices that
favor the majority tend to evolve so
the justice system rotten to the core
actually it has nothing to do with
justice it's simply
another interest group set up to benefit
that dread element of society white
men it does not have to do with justice
rotten to the core do you see the
problem here
do you see the problem with a totally
rotten
justice system that maintains its power
through
implicit actions
if the whole system is corrupt and if
the corruption is implicit then the
training
ain't going to do squat the training it
can't do anything
one even if under the best of conditions
if the whole system is corrupt you got
to get rid of the system
if there's nothing salvageable if it's
rotten really to its core
you've just got to get rid of it you've
got to say abolish the police
but furthermore if the corruption is
implicit then there's nothing you can do
about it
because you can only do things about
about
issues that come to the conscience that
that
are brought up in your reason that you
can think through because you can see
them
you can only do things about these
explicit problems
if they are implicit by definition
you you can't control it this is how the
left
maintains power is if they say you're a
racist and i say no i'm really not
and they say no well that's just what a
racist would say you see because if you
if you say that you're not a racist
that's proof that you're a racist
because
the racism that you're not even aware
that your racism is implicit you're not
even aware that you're not aware of your
racism
uh okay well if that's the case then get
rid of this police department
if it's really rotten to the core and
there's nothing you can do about the
biases then just get rid of it right
is that is that what we're going to do
no no it's
just another cudgel to grab
power this is true at the local level
it's true all the way up to the
president ben is going to be talking
about
the president lying like a rug as he
says in his show today go check out
ben's show
later on also you got to check out the
candace owens show we got a new episode
coming out this friday you can still
check out
friday's episode this past friday's
episode really great guests on there
brandon tatum
you've got bryson gray you've got a
really handsome
swarthy articulate brilliant guest i'm
not going to say who it is
go check it out the show is only
available to daily wire
members go to dailywire.com subscribe
use code candace to get 25
off that is code canvas for 25 off join
now
so you can tune in friday night for a
closer look behind her hot takes we'll
be right back with a lot more
as a matter of justice and crime
i can't believe we haven't even talked
about it yet this week
the nation is on trial did you know that
i didn't know that i thought well here's
what i thought i thought that that cop
derek chauvin who was the minnesota cop
who was
involved in the death of george floyd
and some people
are like blm for instance is saying that
that derek chovin murdered him and
that there therefore justified blm
burning the country down for six months
and some people are saying well actually
you know george floyd
was resisting arrest because we saw that
video and he had
extraordinarily toxic levels of fentanyl
in his system
and he has to be taken out of the car
and so maybe this is more complicated
than people are letting on i don't know
i don't want to get my studio burned
down for saying something like that by
the social justice warriors
but i thought it was a very specific
criminal case no
the journalists are telling me on abc
news
this is about the whole country
of course we have no idea over the
course of this trial how much
race will be brought up how much the
conversation that ensued in this country
and really around the world
after this but there's no question
that's the lens through which so many
people are watching this unfold
definitely about race and and i don't
have to tell you david that
this case is so much bigger than what
happened 10 months ago in the corner of
38th in chicago in minneapolis
on its face derek shobin is on trial for
sure
but for many americans this nation is on
trial our criminal justice system
is on trial and for many especially
black people
this is about black and white this is
about
justice for people who aren't
specifically involved in this case
yeah okay that might be true
according to some people and in their
perception but the thing is
those people who think that are wrong
because this case is not about black and
white
and a national reckoning on race and all
these people who are not involved in the
trial
this case is about whether or not the
blm narrative
is true did in this particular case even
if it weren't for in this particular
case it wouldn't necessarily follow that
it's true in all these other cases
but the question in this case the blm
narrative is this
cop motivated by racial hatred
murdered this guy who had done nothing
wrong
and therefore this was this was a hate
crime it was
basically a lynching is that true
the evidence doesn't seem to suggest
it's true but i guess that's why we're
having a trial
because evidence is going to be
presented and we're going to find out
whether
whether that narrative holds up to a
jury or not
it's not about anything else the left
wants to make this about a national
reckoning on race and
more specifically because they don't
want any sort of reckoning on race at
all
they want to advance a narrative that
says that white people
are bad and they're the source of all
evil in the world and
as lebron james said black men can't
leave their homes without being hunted
down by racist whites
and that's that's what they're going to
to tell us because that isn't an
effective
cudgel there was a really horrific
apparent hate crime in new york just uh
just
came out over the past few days
anti-asian violence is on the rise we've
been told the cause of this is white
supremacy so
you can take a take a listen to what
what happened to new york
so an asian woman walking by
yeah we've blurred this too because we
don't i don't want to see this woman
getting
pounded so asian woman walking on the
street
and a black guy walks up and just kicks
her right in the face and then just
keeps kicking her in the face
there's a security guard inside the
building with the door open
so is he going to go help they're not
helping at all is he going to go out
there and help her now
no he closes the door closes the door on
her
as far as i can tell no white supremacy
present anywhere in this video as far as
i can tell no white people present
anywhere in this video
and yet we are being told i kid you not
that crimes such as this perpetrated by
one
racial minority group against another
racial minority group
are caused by white supremacy
because white supremacy is not the
conclusion of any argument the left is
making it's the premise
it's the lens through which they're
viewing the world so they'll say yeah
okay this black guy comes up
and he says to this asian woman you
don't belong here and he kicks her in
the head
and he viciously beats her and these
these
i don't even want to call them men these
things standing in this this doorway not
helping her closing the door on her
they do nothing
but this is caused by white supremacy it
reminds me of this uh
rather christian idea that man is the
the greatest of all
beings right of all created beings
and so when man turns toward god he he
really shines right he really is the
greatest greatest of all
beings but when man turns away from god
and embraces
wrath and violence and viciousness like
the man on the street
or when he embraces cowardice and
selfishness like those men in the
building
he becomes the worst of all animals the
lowest
of the created things and that's i think
what we're seeing
in this video is the issue that's going
on in this video is it white supremacy
uh no very obviously not
is it race well there's obviously a
racial component there the guy says to
the asian woman you don't belong here
so it it at least seems very likely that
race plays some role
but is race even the primary issue here
i don't think so
i think the primary issue is a total
breakdown of
civil society i think the issue is a
complete breakdown of education
i suspect at issue here is a breakdown
of the family which teaches you
love loyalty and obligation to the
smallest political unit up to the larger
political unions
and i suspect what's going on here is a
breakdown of the justice system
that guy who kicked that woman in the
face apparently he's been arrested
thankfully
apparently he uh he just got out of the
clink a little while ago he served 17
years after murdering his mother
a guy murders his mother goes to jail
for 17 years if you murder your mother
i don't want to seem like i'm a crazy
bloodthirsty pro-capital punishment guy
if you murder your mother i don't think
you should get out of prison
i don't think you should go to prison i
think you should be executed by the
state
i don't see any exception to that rule
right is that so crazy
am i such a radical for saying that but
no because we
we now are told we need to be
compassionate we need to it's so
compassionate
and it's actually a matter of justice to
pull people out of the justice system
and let them out on the street so they
can kick asian women in the head
is that is that compassionate is that
justice i
i don't think so speaking of potential
crimes
under investigation right now for
allegedly getting frisky with the 17
year old girl is
republican congressman matt gates
apparently under
fbi or doj investigation uh matt gates
says that it's an extortion attempt
involving a crooked doj official
i'll give them the benefit of the doubt
i don't know i mean i don't know
anything about this case
the only thing i know is that there is
corruption at the doj
plenty of fine people at the doj and the
fbi but also plenty of crooks
we saw a lot of them during the trump
administration we know matt gates
very prominent republican we know
republicans have it pretty tough these
days
when it comes to the administrative
state so i'll give him the benefit of
the doubt i don't know maybe it maybe
did maybe didn't
i i'm going to reserve judgment i know
that that's a crazy thing to do these
days where we're all supposed to have a
knee-jerk reaction right away and and
you know throw people into the outer
darkness where there's wailing and
gnashing of teeth but i'm not going to
do that
you know wait and say they're going to
do some investigation we'll see what
happens what's more interesting about
matt gates right now
is that he has reportedly told several
associates
that he is considering leaving congress
and going over to newsmax and becoming a
newsmax tv host
now really the only reason i even
mentioned the sex scandal thing
is that this might be one explanation
for why he wants to leave congress
but let's just say for a second they're
separate issues
i think there's two reads on why a
prominent member of congress would want
to leave congress to become a tv show
host
the cynical read is that he wants money
and he wants fame you can't make a whole
lot of money in congress at least not if
you want to do it the honest way
and you know you get sort of well-known
but you you can be
just as well-known if not more
well-known in the media and so yeah he
wants more
more money and fame so he's gonna gonna
leave public service
that's a cynical read there's a
sympathetic read too and it's the one
that i'm more inclined toward
the sympathetic read is that matt gates
knows that he can have
a greater influence in our public life
from a desk at newsmax
than he can in congress and i i think
that's basically true
there there have been a handful of times
people write in many of you have written
in and said hey michael are you
do you want to run for public office you
should run for for office
and i i think well yeah if i if i felt i
could really do something certainly i
would do that
that'd be great if i felt that i could
really influence
the country in a way that i felt was
really good and and i could do oh man
wouldn't that be fabulous
can one do that in certain instances i
think one can
can you do that from congress though i
don't think so
because congress doesn't really pass
laws anymore
certainly republicans in congress don't
pass laws democrats do it a little bit
more so
but mostly what you do if you're in
congress is you just
do tv hits right you occasionally will
get a good sound bite
when you're grilling someone who's
testifying and then
you're flying back and forth all the
time between your district and dc and
you're just raising money you're
spending probably 60 percent of your
time
just calling up your friends and
associates and begging for money
and then you're spending the rest of
your time doing tv hits
so and and really the way you're
influencing the public conversation is
much more
through the tv hits than through
anything else so i suspect what matt
gates is thinking is way to say why am i
wasting all my time
doing these things that are having no
effect whatsoever when i could just
spend all my time doing the tv hits and
make it a tv show and have an influence
that way
obviously when it is the case that the
media
have more influence over our politics
than elected members of congress
something has gone a little weird in our
constitutional order
but i i do think that's happened and i
think
gates i think there are plenty of
unselfish reasons why he would want to
go
have a tv show instead of serving
congress
the left knows that people in the media
can have a wider impact on our you know
much more significant impact on our
politics than people in congress
that is why they spend so much time
going after us in media
there are people who are watching this
right now i suspect
who are at organizations like media
matters which is an extraordinarily
well-funded left-wing operative group
whose job it is to watch this show
that's their job never say i'm not a job
creator
their job is to sit and watch this show
and try to get me fired and it's not
just me it's
ben shapiro it's andrew clavin
it's some of the fox guys some of the
newsmax guys some of the blaze guys
and they may have just claimed a scalp
there was a a big
recent coordinated effort for media
matters to go after stephen crowder
i guess there's always kind of a long
coordinated effort to go after crowder
frankly i'm i'm part of the effort to go
after crowder you know we got to bring
that guy down a pic
no there is there's the left is going
after crowder a lot because he gets away
with a lot because he's a comedian and
he's a pretty funny guy
now they're closing in on him youtube
has blocked
crowder from uploading new content to
his channel for one week he's got a huge
channel it's got over five million
subscribers i think
uh he's got another separate channel
called crowder bits that i think he's
still streaming from run we'll see how
long that stays up
uh they pulled one of his videos from
the platform that's that they said
violated its rules against spreading
misinformation about the 2020 election
youtube booted crowder from its youtube
partner program which allows
crowder to monetize the show it's not
like he does the show as a charity right
the show is his job that's how he can
produce a high quality show that's gone
for some other reason that they made up
he's being booted from twitter maybe
he's back on twitter now i'm not sure
but this is what happens is that all the
tech companies when they think you're
vulnerable when they think it's a good
time to go after they just
they go in on them i had an interview
with stephen yesterday when i was guest
hosting ben's radio show you can find
that over at my youtube channel
because he kind of explains what's going
on here the reason i bring this up is
not just to complain about how big tech
is going after conservatives we all know
that that's happening
the reason i mention this is
crowder is very very mainstream
okay i spend a lot of my day
reading things from the fringe of the
fringe of the far left
and reading things from the fringe of
the fringe of the far right
and reading a lot of arcane old
political philosophy
from the way old back timey days and
reading a lot of
what crazy people are saying now and
watching all these crazy youtube videos
steven crowder is about as mainstream as
it gets
okay and if they're going after him
they're going after all of us it's why i
mention i mean i've been making a joke
about it now that i keep plugging my
book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds whether it was coincidence or
let's say providence my book is about
this
about what's going on right this very
second even though i started writing it
a year and a half ago
and now that amazon is booting
conservative books
i don't know how much longer it's going
to be up there so it's available for
pre-order now at other places
and it's still at amazon for now we'll
see how long that lasts
things happen gradually and then
suddenly so it might be yeah they're
kicking off the fringe people and then
you know six months later they kick off
some other fringe guy and then
that's a little less fringe six months
later and
you could see a world where where it
goes crowder blaze
daily wire boom boom boom boom boom
because they know that the media can
have great influence and they don't want
us to have any
say in the media
speaking of getting cancelled
you know there was an attempt by
harry's razors to cancel me the other
day
do you remember harry's razors i used to
advertise on the show they make they
make good razors
don't they i mean a lot of people i know
have bought razors through this show
from harry's and i know that a lot of
people have canceled their razors from
harry so
so harry's responded to a
fake twitter account this account that
had at the time two followers
who knows who's behind the account it
could be some high school kid or it
could be a democrat operative
outlet like the ones we've just
mentioned which have lots and lots of
twitter accounts who knows i don't know
i don't really care
that twitter account dug up a clip from
two years ago in which i
i went on candace owens's old show on
prager
and candace owens made a point about
transgenderism and i agreed with it
and this twitter account said harry's
you're sponsoring michael knowles you
this is
terrible look what he did years ago
before you even started sponsoring him
and harry's wrote back and they said
this is inexcusable
we condemn these views you know the view
that men are not women or whatever
and we condem and this is horrible and
we've ended our relationship with this
show
and i thought i think they believed they
were just going to virtue signal to the
left-wing mob it wasn't even a mob it
was this little fake account
and that would be all good and we'd let
them get away with it and if it were
just to hit at me you know maybe i'd
just take it move on
but it was a hit at our listeners it was
a hit our audience who said
said you know if you believe that men
are not women that you're an inexcusable
vile bigot or something
so we decided we were not going to be
quiet about it we were going to
mention that harry's razors does not
want the business of conservatives
because harry's razors thinks we're all
vile and condemnable and inexcusable
harry's razors
hates us they don't mind our money
because our money's still green
but they don't really want our they
don't want any relationship with us
that's for sure
they said there's a values misalignment
so anyway i've gotten
at this point i think thousands of
messages
from people who who have written into
harry's to cancel their plans
and have cc'ed me on emails
apparently for what some people were
calling harry's and saying hey i wanna i
i just heard something on the michael
knowles show and harry's would preempt
them and say well
we're canceling your plan so so anyway
that's pretty funny good way to uh keep
pressure up
really really too bad that harry's
doesn't doesn't want our business
speaking of getting canceled
maryland the state of maryland what
could have been that great catholic
colony that great catholic state didn't
didn't remain very catholic too long
maryland is getting rid of its state
anthem the state song
is maryland my maryland and
you're going to see some commentary on
this over the next few days
and it's some people are going to say
this is cancelled culture and some
people are gonna say
this is wonderful that they're changing
the song and i think most of the debate
is is missing the point
here's the song maryland my maryland
the despot's heel is on thy shore
maryland
his torch is at thy temple door maryland
avenge the patriotic gore that flecked
the streets of baltimore
and be the battle queen of yore maryland
my maryland
the despot that they're referring to
here is abraham lincoln
so this uh this song comes from i guess
the
1860s and it was uh made the state
song in in 1939 i believe
uh maryland my mother state to the i
kneel maryland for life and death for
woe and wheel the peerless chivalry
reveal and gird thy beauteous limbs with
steel maryland
my maryland then it goes on and talks
more about
maryland virginia should not call in
vain maryland she meets her sisters on
the plane sex semper tis
the proud refrain that baffles minions
back
again maryland the six emperor like six
emperor tyrannus thus always to tyrants
it's what
john wilkes booth yelled when he killed
abraham lincoln so
this is pretty you know pretty hardcore
it obviously does have a
relation to the confederacy it obviously
doesn't take a good
good view of abraham lincoln
so should we keep the anthem in the
interest of
preserving our history should we get rid
of the anthem because
you know it's a it's a confederate
battle cry basically
what's the answer my problem
is not exactly the repeal of the song
the song hasn't been the state song for
all that long considering how long
maryland's existed
and it's not the song that wasn't even
written all that long ago
my problem here is how contrived the
whole thing is i do not think that there
is a popular movement
to get rid of the maryland state song
i suspect most marylanders don't know
the state song and have never heard of
the state song
this is not an organic change this is a
a another example of feigning offense
on behalf of allegedly oppressed people
this is this is just another example of
people pretending and pretending
this is also purely destructive
there's no it's not as though everyone's
always singing the state song
and now you know this has created a big
conflict and so now we need a new state
song and there's a battle between the
state songs and one state song is on the
rise
no it's just some busybody liberal
probably a white liberal if i just if i
had to guess i'm
only speaking anecdotally it's usually
how these things go going in
and saying this is unacceptable we can't
have this song and so we're just going
to get rid of it because we're going to
pretend to be offended on behalf of
everybody
but there's nothing to replace it
it seems to me the conservative approach
to something like this is
if the state song no longer represents
who you are
then you change it you you replace it
with something that is
has really that is a true ritual that
has become a tradition
that actually means something in the
hearts of the people
you engage in evolution not revolution
gradual
change from a a real place of concern
and love of state
i don't think that any of what's going
on with the maryland state song
has to do with gradual change or organic
change
or love of state for that matter i think
it's people who think
maryland racist bad evil we've got to
get rid of it america
evil racist too gotta you gotta get rid
of that gotta topple the statues
gotta destroy the old standards
this is the phenomenon i described in in
the book speechless is
it there is this campaign to
a purely negative campaign to destroy
all the traditions imperfect though some
of our ideas might be
you know not politically correct though
some of our behaviors might be
there's this campaign to get rid of all
the old standards
and what are they going to be replaced
with i don't know speech codes that
change every day doesn't matter
what it's about is the accumulation of
power
and the imposition of that power by the
big interests in the private sector in
the government and the culture
that have really benefited from this
crisis
oops dare dare i say it the crisis that
we're in
i'm michael moses the michael knowles
shows you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
board
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matt welsh show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show